in den röhren den wendenden wenden
er klatscht und nach die alten betrifft
zusammen
herzlich willkommen zurück kamera dem
kupferstecher halli hallo hallo heute ja
was willst du mir einreden erwartet
naja ich rede dir gerne immer rein also
macht versprach dafür über was ich habe
so ein tagebuch da rede ich immer das
schreibe 18 uhr 23 konnte erfolgreich
eingeredet okay jedenfalls bei mir heute
ohne kämen weil die speicherkarte voll
ist alter eine von den acht milliarden
youtube money geldern da kannst du dir
auch achim neumann die gelder ganz
kaufte jedoch da einfach mal fünf
terabyte aber dass ich immer noch eine
milliarde abgeben er stimmt dann bleibt
nicht mehr so viel dann noch die lambo
kosten halt für sprit und diese schätze
sprung in die hand
die provisorische taktik von crafter
wenn ich darunter vergeblich vor der
hütte wir haben uns hingegen zeit
gekostet gepostet wir haben die ganze
zeit vor ort und auf einmal waren wir
eine komplett antritt platz als hätten
wir zwar anders
das heißt überhaupt hier immer wieder ja
ja ja ich habe es geschafft ich auch
mein gott jetzt report zur kultur hier
ist kein publikum hier wieder raus
sprünge nach verstehen wer ich sei so
carls da wir spaß die konnte
ja nein darum weil ich nicht ganz so ein
finden die fma
du weißt doch noch die folge wo ich den
einpark übersprung habe dann habe ich
hab mir merken dann mal wieder links
schnell auf jeden fall kann die folge
auch folgt also ich fand das voll
korrekt eigentlich dass die leute nicht
immer nur darauf gucken ok ich hab
keinen gefunden
im wasser predigt nicht
ich habe elf coins ja wohl wenn ich das
teil noch aufholen damit die aufholjagd
jahrhundert außerdem vergab bei mir viel
zu heftig deswegen kann es können müssen
wir ihn überhaupt lang leben da anlegen
sagte motto
so okay bin nur auf kisten fokussiert
aber auch die spiele gehen wenn die
immer so wären ich habe blatt
kaputtgemacht bist ja deswegen bin ich
runtergefallen
deswegen ist runtergefallen ab deswegen
bin ich darüber springen kann
oh nein jetzt liegst du da rum
ich habe deinen blog präpariert kein
rundum zu fliegen doch einfach nur tt
com htt der welt bin nicht mehr die
folge tpg hdcp comer see frau dazu muss
ein remix ntt com http natürlich
einbauen damit weiter michael thomas
ganswindt das klatschen und den dubstep
dieses
klatsch und sagt die ganze zeit
mister bean da war was das la torre los
ich bin jetzt muss oder mut zu sein
du hast das minecraft mister bla bla bla
und ich war dabei
das haben wir nie ermöglichen
trotzdem will auch was ab
das wird geil es ist noch hell als wenn
wir das erstmal direkt verrechnet
wo ich ja alle die luft
ich glaube ich
die werke weg sind wir durch durch die
karte na ja ich glaube schon
bis richtiges talent nein wir haben da
noch irgendwas vergessen bestimmt jedoch
noch wundert provider oder löse nicht
irgendwie komisch abgerundet werden die
uns cnt geben sonst müsste ich dachte
die princess und als aber dabei die
priester weise ein bild aber nicht
genauer komplett auf das bild kurz da
steht auf dem bild 1 bis 2 underground
mai manhattan stars bevor du was cool
ist einfach lena ex boss sepp blatter
aber hier geht es doch noch weiter hier
waren wir aber auch schon weil ich
möchte nochmals sicher gehen ob wir hier
wirklich nichts vergessen haben
irgendwie schade okay ich mache doch
lieber bei dir mit mir irgendwie glaube
ich ein ganzer berg euro der berg ist so
wie kann ich dich noch mal ihr ärgern
frage ich mich gerade wie ich habe 17
konntest du ich habe elf ok dann habe
ich das gewonnen
du hast als teil gewonnen wir können
einfach in die kommentare schreiben dass
es am coolsten fahrkarten ob eventuell
weitere karten volt und was für
vorschläge gehabt weil wieder ein
offenes entwicklerteams liga und wird
karte findet und wir sollten finde ich
nochmal der bewertung der karte als
lebens oder ja gut eigentlich fand ja
auch eigentlich jeder hat gut hinein wie
immer alles geklappt eigentlich ich bin
ein netter lehrer ich gebe auch eine 1
also jetzt aber was ich hier für tnt
schlange gelegt habe
siehst du das nein komplett um die insel
herum einfach nach vorne schon eine
filiale sex and the city bin ist alles
deins leidet will das so nicht
doch auch hier der sprengmeister hast du
da überhaupt schon erfahrungen drin also
darfst du das machen wir natürlich ja
natürlich sagt prof
der sprengmeister schlechthin merkel man
ja explodieren los meine kleine meine
freundin dach hier englisch nachkommt
kom kom kom kom kommt ja wohl die karte
muss oder dass ihr held möchte auch gern
sterben oder alleine was auf das contra
ich glaube da will gerne mal sternen
ich rette dich skelett los ins wasser ja
ich hab's gerettet
er ist mein bester freund das wird sich
ja ich finde ich jetzt voll witzig aber
richtig wahr machen würde ja der inventa
behältst du ja verdammt dachte ist so
voll aebischer accounts weg alles weg
aber nein natürlich nicht
es gibt immer ein haken an der ganzen
sache hat das war gerade so für ein paar
folgen wo du mich immer wieder
geschlagen hast von allen möglichen
plätzen was werden dass das ist ja toll
der macht spaß
ich wollte mich jetzt einfach hier ein
ganz ehrlich so einfach nach unten
das weglassen würde den haben aber nicht
gleich kommt
die luft war wie viele tnt kann ein
konkreter aushalten wie fick cnc kann
ein gome aushalten
also das hältst du auch nicht aus ich
erfinde schon mal für dich auf den weg
mit dir ich habe es ausgehalten
naja wegen seiner extrem rüstung guckt
ihr noch einmal ein purist panzer an das
sowas von heftig also wenn der nicht
öffentlich ist da weiß ich auch nicht
mehr weiter gute freunde das war dass
auf jeden fall wollen wir jetzt auch gar
nicht weiter eure tolle zeit wegnehmen
stück kohle gefunden endlich gab gleich
die raten gefunden hat was ja preisen
gefunden ok jemanden wenn ich hier
diamanten finden welche einfach noch
unter baut dann bin ich da der überflug
bei pröll wird immer so überbewertet
neil okay hier ist nur der kunst stand
aber auch die freunde ich würde sagen
wir sehen und ja ich mit aussage der
schülern mit ösen ganz genau nimmt